this is what we do okay you got to stay
for it because I know you have a show to
do what is it it's called unhelpful
advice okay you know you didn't let do
somebody call it no we have an email all
right was going to it got it
a helpful advice with Bobby kalila and
Chris silly goose time D'Elia
I'm in the military I'm married and have
a stepchild I lied to everybody in my
unit that he's mine and I'm and now I'm
getting out I want to stay friends with
some people I grew up on the deployment
with and they're my best friends how do
I tell them I'm a scumbag do I tell them
or do I take it to the [ __ ] grave
wait what why because he lied to
everyone and said that was his
biological child yeah he was embarrassed
to say that it's a stepchild oh what's
up first why would you be ashamed that
he's your stepchild because I think is
that the email where he says that people
are like oh he looks like you and he
kind of just goes with it the very ends
by the way my wife isn't on it and it's
hilarious because everyone says my
stepson
my stepson and I look alike because
we're Mexican so it's really his stepson
but he tells but he tells people that he
it's his real biological and so it's
it's a it's a white lie that doesn't
really hurt anybody
give me another email no he wants to be
remain friends with his EP lifeline
dippy but he doesn't want to be lying to
them after he gets out I lie every day
right serious lies right well that's a
serious lot all right so it's like and I
free I have winked true right and you
are aware it's a white lie you are
wearing an army shirt exactly and I was
in the Navy
oh really that was the Navy see you're
in the Navy see yeah yeah great great on
help I'm a border Mongoose real an
animal yeah Wow you just throw it out
there right and see if it sticks some
people will believe yeah that's a real
word that is just another you know he
said he shouldn't say don't say no I
think you should but I don't think his
friends would think it was anything
serious either no just be like oh I was
just [ __ ] I don't know why I said
that it was it started as a joke and I
was [ __ ] around and yes not mine but
dude and then if somebody goes like this
oh that's not cool be like yo I'm nuttin
your girl and have a kid that way if you
don't let's take it to the real daddy
how about that
the kid is is this is not not work bro
what part of a female it's not what
heard of the email I know but it has
nothing to do with it but what colored
is he wearing right now yeah no but I
want to know if this note works you're
gonna have to taste it there's one way
and if I taste it and it squirms in my
mouth like if I say
[Music]